oh yeah there's a new game mode for GTA
online it's called every bullet counts
you can check for those red adversary
mode prompts on your phone but you're
better off leaning towards the Rockstar
playlist every bullet count so what is
this mode exactly it's a four-person
free-for-all Last Man Standing hunt only
the catch is you only start with two
bullets per round and there's no auto
aim so once you're out of ammo you're
resorting to your ex or machete making
for some frantic last kills now how do
you reign supreme in this intense game
mode well let's take a look at some
pointers number one yes you only get two
shots but keep an eye out for extra ammo
scattered around the map sankei sionally
dead dudes in Michaels mansion on every
bullet count one for example has a gun
in the front entrance by the stairs
always keep moving if you thought you
could post up behind some cover and
surprise someone think again staying put
for too long will ping your location on
the mini-map we're all other hunters to
see get creative with your tactics be
unpredictable and flank those slimy box
once more take Michael's mansion for
instance if you know there's a party
going on upstairs don't take the main
stairway hole outside and climb on the
garage overhang and bam surprise on the
flip don't rinse and repeat too often be
sure to change your game plan often
enough to keep them guessing stealth you
should be using sneak like the whole
time which will quiet your movement
further mask your presence by avoiding
easily lockable objects and glass doors
once you got your stealth on lock
concentrate and put your ear to the
floor many times you'll be able to hear
someone upstairs or hopping around
outside when it comes down to those
sticky melee situations more often than
not whoever gets the first hit will
claim the belt so if you don't consider
backing off and trying something
different utilize cover obviously being
behind cover is a good thing but you get
to retain the element of surprise and
roughly line up a shot all the while not
being vulnerable plus spinning out from
cover is insanely quick and it shortens
your exposure window if you're down to
the melee and your opponent has a gun
don't put yourself out in the open
resort to close quarters stay hidden and
cheat the camera to see who's coming if
you know there's a dude heading down the
hallway be the feline you were meant to
be and pounce baby yeah lastly if you're
one of those last two left try not to do
this sticking to one area of the
building and checking the same bathroom
a dozen times is brutal for the
spectators so get in there and be
aggressive
you